[Music]
victorious was one of the most popular
Nickelodeon shows for teenagers and many
fans still can't understand why it ended
so quickly without even getting a final
episode there are many mysteries
surrounding the show and today we'll
tell them all join us as we expose Jory
look at music sales charts talk about
scandals and find out what the parents
actually thought of the show if you're
new here hit that subscribe button to
never miss another video and don't
forget to give us a big thumbs up
now let's expose some of the darkest
secrets Victorious tried to hide ariana
grande and victoria justice so let's
start by getting the cat out of the bag
not literally we're sure Cat Valentine
was never in a bag anyways it's no
secret that over the years more and more
stories came out that ariana grande and
Victoria Justice just didn't get along
from shading each other to Ariana saying
she worked with someone who told her
they'd never liked her and that she got
bullied later
Victoria cleared out those groomers by
saying ariana was talking about someone
she worked on a show called Broadway
Victoria also became a huge meme after
she said that the entire cast could sing
when Ariana was singled out as a
talented singer she quickly got branded
as Petty and remains one of the reasons
why the show potentially ended hey guys
we are so excited to announce we are
producing our own original content head
over to the trendy for the best DIYs
fashion tips makeup hacks and so much
more we are sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us
the common affection he left me here
pannu see you there
it was victorious fault so let's look at
some of the secrets Victoria Justice had
more closely in 2015 there seemed to
have been even more rumors floating
around that the show getting canceled
was entirely Victoria's fault the rumor
that Victoria was going to do a solo
tour instead of the cast tour made the
fans think she was leaving her
co-workers behind to start her own music
career it doesn't help her case that
ariana held a victorious reunion in 2016
without Victoria Victoria addressed the
rumors and stated she had nothing to do
with the cancellation of the show do you
think she's telling the truth
jealousy from the cast some say that the
cast were all so jealous of Ariana's
immediate success if you look at the
first season of Victoria's you might
find that the profiles of the two
singers were relatively similar
everything was fine until ariana was
cast on a Victoria spinoff show and
started receiving more limelight than
any other cast the success of her song
the way was likely a result of her
success on Victorious and even though
she wasn't a lead character on the show
Victoria song gold didn't have the same
charting success as grande was starting
to bring more and more money into her
project and made Victoria jealous this
could also be the reason behind her
petty I think we can all say in comment
Victoria Justice pictures leaked did you
know that Victoria justices private
photos leaked online back in 2014 by the
time it happened the show was already
cancelled but even though Victoria
denied these were her photos at first
she later admitted they belong to her no
one wants to have their private photos
leaked especially not if you're an
underage Nickelodeon star although the
scandal became international news it got
quickly forgotten as Victoria took legal
actions against the hackers who exposed
her privacy although it's highly
unlikely this had anything to do with
Victorious it probably did affect
Nickelodeon's image and their
professional relationship with Victoria
for any future work
we're Elizabeth and Victoria dating a
tumblr blog called TV cancellation
theories comes up with a lot of
potential secrets shows like victorious
tried to hide and what resulted in them
being cancelled keep in mind that this
is just a theory and it should
definitely be taken with a grain of salt
if you loved Tori Vega and Jade West you
were most likely a jewelry shipper who
desperately wanted the two characters to
be together fans still speculate that
the two were actually in a relationship
and Nickelodeon didn't approve in 2016
Victoria and Elizabeth had a victorious
reunion all by themselves and they
proved that Jory is definitely still
alive do you think they're more than
just cast mates and friends problematic
Ariana we've already talked about how
the cast especially Victoria were most
likely jealous of ariana grande the
immediate success but Ariana's
beginnings were extremely problematic
for a Nickelodeon star it seems that
ariana was not only potentially feuding
with Victoria but there also seems to be
a salmon cat cast member who really
didn't like working with the famous
singer we all remember Ariana's donut
licking incident from her early days but
it looks like the star might have been
pretty problematic on set
although jennette mccurdy stated that
her and Ariana but it heads in a very
sisterly way she posted a tweet about an
anonymous person and said that every
time they hung out she was in a
quicksand because she was getting
completely lost in her world who do you
think this was actually about the
creator wanted it to continue it's still
unclear why the show canceled in the
first place but from what it seems like
everyone really wanted victorious to
continue even the show's creator Dan
Schneider took it to Twitter to address
some of the show's rumors he stated that
he would love to have made more than 60
victorious episodes and that he knows
some of the fans are upset and angry
then he said that the fans shouldn't be
upset with Victoria Leon Liz Ariana Ava
nor any other members of the cast as
they all wanted the show to continue it
really seems that nickelodeon put their
foot down when it came to canceling the
show even though nobody wanted it to
happen but why
they really didn't want it to end even
though it seems like Victoria is blamed
for the cancellation of the show it
looks like she really didn't want it to
end
in fact she took it to Twitter and wrote
a very lengthy letter on why she's
grateful for victorious she even wrote
her very own ending since the show never
got a season finale
according to Victoria Tori gets a record
deal and becomes a pop star Andre is
also a pop star as well as a writer and
producer
Trina gets accepted to the new season of
The Bachelor Beck gets cast in his own
series and Kat marries Robbie and starts
her own babysitting service with Sam
make sure to let us know your own
version a victorious fairy final episode
in the comments their music was
successful here's another possible
theory why Victoria
got the unexpected boot unlike movies
like High School Musical and shows like
Glee the Chris just didn't feature
charting music that would make up for
the production costs even though the
show had two million average viewers and
was one of the most popular team shows
on Nickelodeon the sales of the cast
music didn't produce the same results
the victorious soundtrack debuted on the
Billboard 200 at number five and sold
40,000 copies meanwhile Ariana's debut
song sold 2.3 million copies as of March
2016
since nickelodeon seemed to only focus
on ariana grande success it could be the
victorious average sales just weren't
enough to continue with the show parents
hated the show and lastly the show
didn't seem to have much support from
the parents even though their kids loved
the show the parents just didn't seem to
get on board with many things including
victorious as inappropriate jokes the
parents have criticized rude characters
who seem to have absolutely no manners
according to them the show also features
a lot of pushover parents who seem to
have no control over their kids lives
and create a false reality of how a
teenager is supposed to act in the real
world
some even criticize that the show
focuses way too much on girls being
liked by boys and doesn't bring enough
diversity to be an educational
Nickelodeon show could this be why
Nickelodeon finally decided to pull the
plug on Victorious let us know what
secrets we should expose next
for more videos like this one check out
10 funniest adult jokes in victorious
you might have missed see you next time
[Music]